my name is Allen Blanchard I'm from Long
Island New York an undergrad at MIT and
I'm studying material science and
engineering Europe stands for
undergraduate research opportunities
program they're really giving you the
resources to like put any idea down on
the table and experiment with it I
opened up literature and I read and I'm
just like you know if I take a B and C
and I put them together like do you
think this can work it was like I don't
know let's just let's just try it out
and see what's happening and it's
something new and it's something that
when you think about it it's something
of your own too so that's really what
makes it fun
I wanted to do something in regards to
the energy problem with alternative
energy sources like solar and wind
they're intermittent when there's lots
of Sun if you have a storage device and
store that energy and you give it to you
when there's not a lot of Sun then you
can make this a feasible energy solution
but the thing now is the storage devices
we have like lithium-ion they're
incredibly expensive so it's almost
$1,000 per kilowatt hour in some cases
you need a device that's $100 per
kilowatt hour so that's 10 times cheaper
to make this a feasible concept so the
liquid metal battery a key concept
behind this is you're gonna have three
layers all in the liquid state you're
gonna have on the bottom a dense metal
lay in the middle that's the molten salt
and then the top layer is the light
metal the beauty behind the entire
system really is that you can put them
all in the same cell heat them up and
they're going to assemble by the
relative densities of each of these
components what I've been working on is
making the battery more robust more
efficient I'm exploring just new
chemistry's in general when you have all
the components ready you take the cell
and this is where you do a lot of your
work it's full with argon and argon you
know is an inert gas so get really
accurate results and also you make sure
that you're safe because nothing really
explodes in this environment however
there's some drawbacks in the sense that
when you're working with the gloves here
and it takes about two to three times
longer to do any process we try to use
an entirely new category of electrolytes
we were really lucky to get some really
great data and now we're trying to push
it even further to see if we can
increase the capacity and the multitude
of ways we develop something that is
close to $100 per kilowatt hour now so
it's bringing in the alternative energy
sources and also it's going to allow the
grid to be a lot more energy efficient
so it's cutting on both regimes and when
you see that come together that's like a
pretty amazing feat
with this new device it's gonna spark a
new economy because private homes could
even store energy at night and then sell
it back to the grid the next morning I
think a lot of the consistency that's
been in my undergraduate experience has
been in research and getting the skills
to learn how to solve new and
challenging problems